สวัสดีค่ะครูฟ้า
สวัสดีค่ะครูหญิงสวัสดีค่ะนักเรียนสวัสดี
ค่ะนักเรียนครูฟ้าวันนี้วันอะไรคะวันนี้
วันอาทิตย์ค่ะ
ค่ะวันที่เท่าไหร่คะ
วันที่
10 เดือนอะไรคะ
เดือนกันยายน
ปีพ.ศอะไรคะ
ปีพ.ศ
อะไรคะ
ปีค.ศ
2023 ค่ะ
เมื่อวานนี้วันอะไรคะ
เมื่อวานนี้วันเสาร์
วันที่เท่าไหร่คะ
วันที่ 9
เดือนอะไรคะ
เดือนกันยายน
ปีพ.ศอะไรคะ
ปีพ.ศ
อะไรคะ
ปีค.ศ
2023 ค่ะค่ะพรุ่งนี้วันอะไรคะ
พรุ่งนี้วันจันทร์วันที่เท่าไหร่คะ
วันที่ 11 เดือนอะไรคะ
เดือนกันยายน
ปีพ.ศอะไรคะ
ปีพ.ศ
อะไรคะ
ปีค.ศ
2023 ค่ะค่ะตอนนี้เวลากี่โมงคะครูฟ้า
ตอนนี้เวลา 11 โมง
11 โมงกี่นาที
8 นาทีค่ะ
เขียนแค่ไปนะคะไม่พอ 11 โมง 8 นาทีก็เป็น
ตอนกลางวันนะคะ
เป็นตอนกลางวันใช่ไหมคะตอนนี้เนี่ยที่
ประเทศไทยนะคะหรือว่ากรุงเทพฯผู้หญิง
เนี่ยมองออกไปข้างนอก
ที่บ้านถ้าครูฟ้าอยู่บ้านมันก็จะมี
หน้าต่างใช่ไหม
มองออกไปข้างนอกหน้าต่างเนี่ยนะคะเหมือน
ฝนจะตกเลยอ่ะ
เหมือนฝนจะตกหรอ
ใช่ค่ะทำไม
หรอทำไมครูหญิงคิดฝนจะตกคะ
ก็ดูใช่ไหมคะมีก้อนเมฆก้อนเมฆก้อนเมฆก้อน
เมฆมากๆดวงอาทิตย์เนี่ยนะคะ
อยู่ที่ไหนไม่รู้มองไม่เห็นเลยว่าปกติใช่
ไหมถ้าตอนนี้ 11 โมงประเทศไทยนะคะโอ้โห
ดวงอาทิตย์เนี่ย
ใหญ่มาก
[เพลง]
แต่วันนี้เนี่ยมองไม่เห็น
ไม่เห็นดวงอาทิตย์นะคะมีก้อนเมฆ
ก้อนเมฆมากๆไงแล้วแบบร้อนไหม
ก็ร้อนแต่นิดหน่อยนะคะไม่ได้ร้อนมากๆ
นักเรียนเห็นแล้วอาจจะบอกว่านี่นิดหน่อย
หรอ
31 องศาเซลเซียส
[เสียงหัวเราะ]
นิดหน่อยไหม
15 องศานะคะ
15 องศาเซลเซียส
เดี๋ยวอัดวีดีโอกับครูฟ้าเสร็จจะไปข้าง
นอกไงอันนี้บ้านใช่ไหมก็จะไปไปช้อปปิ้งไป
เดินช็อปปิ้งแต่จริงๆถ้าอยู่ประเทศไทย
สบายๆเหมือนกันนะใช่ไหมครูฟ้าอยู่ประเทศ
ไทยเนี่ยช้อปปิ้งสบายค่ะผู้หญิง
เพราะว่าประเทศไทยมีห้าง
นักเรียนห้างนะคะอันนี้อะไร
ห้างมีกี่ชั้นคะครูฟ้า
[ปรบมือ]
[เพลง]
มีชั้น 1 ชั้น 2 ชั้น 3 ชั้น 4 มีหลายๆ
ชั้นอยากซื้อครูหญิงอยากซื้อเสื้อครูฟ้า
อยากซื้อแว่นตา
เพื่อนอยากซื้อสร้อยก็ไปเดินที่ห้างที่
เดียวมีทุกอย่าง
แต่ว่ามันสบายมากนะคะไปชอปปิ้งได้มีช็อป
มีให้ช้อปปิ้งเยอะๆนะคะนักเรียนมีเสื้อ
ใช่ไหมมีแบรนด์หลายๆแบรนด์
ใช่เสื้อก็มีหลายๆๆๆแบรนด์คือถ้านักเรียน
เนี่ยสมมุติว่าเราเป็นครอบครัวใช่ไหมมี
พ่อมีแม่แล้วก็มีลูกมีลูกเนี่ยเป็น 1
ครอบครัวทุกคนคิดอยากซื้อไม่เหมือนกันแต่
ไปเดินห้างไปเดินห้างมีทุกอย่างมีอาหาร
ซื้อหมูซื้อไก่ไปทำอาหารก็ได้ใช่ไหมคะ
ซึ่งหรือว่าซื้อเฟอร์นิเจอร์ก็ยังซื้อได้
เลยนะ
เนี่ย
ค่ะ
ห้างก็มีขายนะคะนักเรียน
ไม่มีนะห้างในประเทศไทยมีนะคะซื้อโต๊ะ
ซื้อเก้าอี้อย่างนี้ค่ะ
ก็ไปเดินห้างก็ได้
ใช่ค่ะมีเยอะนะช้อปปิ้งเยอะๆได้เลย
ใช่ค่ะหรือว่าครูฟ้า
ครูหญิงอยากสวยอยากจะไปฉีดอะไรนะโบท็อกวะ
ให้หน้าสวยๆแต่มันมีเข็มบ้าง
อยากจะไปฉีดโบท็อกที่ห้างก็มีนะนักเรียน
ให้อาหารนักเรียน
ทำหน้าใช่ไหม
ที่ห้างก็มีมีทุกอย่างเพราะว่าห้างที่
กรุงเทพฯหรือว่าที่ไทยเลยเนาะทั้งที่
กรุงเทพฯที่ไทยเนี่ยนะคะมีทุกอย่างแล้วก็
ใหญ่มากๆแต่ว่ามันใหญ่มากๆเนี่ยแหละค่ะ
บางครั้งเราก็ไม่รู้ว่าถ้าครูหญิงไปห้าง
ไม่ไปฉีดโบท็อกนะคะนักเรียนอยากจะไปซื้อ
โต๊ะ
โต๊ะสำหรับทำงานใช่ไหมมีอันนี้ก็จะมีแบบ
มีวางคอมพิวเตอร์
มีไมโครโฟนไว้ทำงานอย่างนี้ค่ะถ้าอยากจะ
ไปซื้อโต๊ะบางครั้งเราก็ไม่รู้ว่าเอ๊ะ
ร้านขายโต๊ะเนี่ยอยู่ชั้น 1 ชั้น 2 ชั้น 3
ชั้น 4 ชั้น 5 ชั้น 6 ชั้น 7 บางครั้งเรา
ก็ไม่รู้ว่าอยู่ที่ไหนอยู่ตรงไหนไปยังไง
เราก็
ใช่ไหมครูฟ้าเนี่ยนะคะเขาไม่ใช่คน
กรุงเทพฯแล้วเมื่อก่อนครูกับครูฟ้า
เซ็นทรัลเวิลด์
เซ็นทรัลเวิลด์พลาซ่าเซ็นทรัล
ที่ใหญ่มากนะคะนักเรียน
เปิด GPS แล้วก็เดินในเซ็นทรัลเวิลด์นะ
ไปเดินเซ็นทรัลเวิลด์บ่อยๆบางครั้งก็ต้อง
Search  Google หานะว่าอยู่ตรงไหนใน
เซ็นทรัลเวิลด์เพราะเซ็นทรัลเวิลด์มันจะ
เป็นแบบนี้เลยเนาะใหญ่ออกมาแบบนี้เลยนะคะ
[เพลง]
มีเซ็นทรัลเวิลด์นะคะใหญ่มากๆถ้าเราเดินๆ
ๆๆ
แล้วก็หาเองเนี่ยนะคะโหบางทีมันเหนื่อย
มากไงเราก็ต้องถามคนอื่นใช่ไหมเราก็ต้อง
ถาม
ห้างทุกที่เนี่ยนะคะเขาก็จะมีเป็น
information หรอแต่คนไทยเรียกอะไรมี
เคาน์เตอร์ถ้านักเรียนเห็นนะคะก็จะเป็น
แบบตัว I อย่างนี้เนาะคิดว่าไม่ใช่แค่
สร้างอย่างเดียวหลายๆที่ถ้าเราเห็นเรา
เป็นเหมือนแบบนี้แล้วก็มีโลโก้วงกลมเป็น
ตัว I เนี่ยนะคะก็คือเราถามได้ถ้าเราไม่
รู้ว่าร้านอยู่ตรงไหนเราก็ถาม
มันถามอะไรคะผู้หญิง
ถามได้ทุกอย่าง
ถ้าเป็นในห้างนะคะแบบไปเซ็นทรัลเวิลด์
พารากอนอย่างนี้เขาก็จะมีคนที่เป็นคนนี้
ใช่ไหมคนนี้ก็เป็นเจ้าหน้าที่นะคะทำงาน
ส่วนนี้ก็เป็นคนมาเดินเนี่ยเราไม่รู้เรา
ก็ถามได้ว่าเออที่ห้างเนี่ยมีร้านขายโต๊ะ
ไหมคะใช่ไหมถ้ามีถ้าผู้หญิงเนี่ยอยากจะ
ซื้อโต๊ะ
แต่ครูหญิงไม่รู้ว่าที่ห้างเนี่ยมีขายไหม
ก็ถามได้นะคะว่าเอ๊ะที่ห้างเนี่ยมีร้าน
ขายโต๊ะไหมคะป้า
ผู้หญิงก็ถามได้ว่า
ฉันไหนฉันหนึ่งฉันสองชั้นสามชั้น 4 ชั้น 5
ใช่ไหมคะเราก็ถามได้ถ้าเราอยากซื้อของคือ
ผู้หญิงคิดว่าถ้าเราไปเดินห้างแล้วเรา
อยากจะซื้อของแล้วเราไม่รู้ว่าอยู่ชั้น
ไหนเราก็ต้องถามคนทำงานนะคะ
แอนจะเรียก information ใช่ไหมเพราะว่า
เป็นตัว I นะ
คะนักเรียนบินมาที่ไทยนักเรียนก็จะไม่รู้
ว่านักเรียนเข้าไปในเซ็นทรัลเวิลด์
อยู่ที่ไหนจะไปกินข้าวที่ไหน
ก็เดินไป information แล้วก็ถามก็โอเคใช่
ไหมใช่ค่ะ
บางครั้งในห้างเราถามคนอื่นที่ไม่ใช่
information เนี่ยเราถามเขาได้ไหม
ถ้าสมมุติครูหญิง
ครูหญิงใช่ไหมแล้วก็ครูฟ้า
เราเนี่ยไปเดินห้างด้วยกันแล้วเราเราไม่
รู้ว่า
information อยู่ที่ไหน
เราไม่รู้แล้วก็มีคนอื่นอาจจะมีผู้ชาย
ผู้หญิง
เขาก็มาเดินห้างเหมือนกัน
ถ้าครูหญิงกับครูฟ้าเนี่ยถามเขาได้ไหมคะ
ถามคนที่เราแบบไม่รู้จักว่าเออ
information อยู่ที่ไหนคะเราถามเขาได้
ไหม
ครูพลอยคิดว่าถามได้นะคะคนไทยใจดี
นะคะแต่ว่าก็ถามเขาเรียกว่าถามคนที่มา
ห้างใช่ไหมคนที่มาเดินช็อปปิ้งมีคนๆๆ
แต่ครูฟ้าจะถาม
ร้านมากกว่า
เพราะว่ากินบางทีคนที่เดินเนี่ยเขาก็ไม่
รู้เหมือนเราเนาะเขาอาจจะมาเดินครั้งแรก
ก็ได้
แต่ถ้าเป็นร้านแบบนี้หรอคะร้านอาหารร้าน
ขายเสื้ออย่างนี้หรอ
ร้านอาหารเนี่ยก็จะมีคนยืนอยู่ใช่ไหม
ที่เขาทำงานอาจจะเสิร์ฟอาหาร
ที่ร้านอาหารใช่ค่ะอุปกรณ์ก็ถามว่า
ครูฟ้าอยากซื้อเสื้อรู้ไหมที่ไหนอย่างนี้
บางคนเขาก็จะอ้อโอเครู้นะคะ
บางคนก็
แต่คิดว่าน่าจะรู้
ได้หรือว่าถ้ายิ่งเป็นถ้าเป็นแบบร้านขาย
เสื้อถามว่าร้านขายที่ไหนเนี่ยบางร้านถ้า
อยู่ชั้นเดียวกันสมมุติว่าร้านอาหารครู
ฟ้าเนี่ยนะคะอันนี้มันเป็นชั้น 1 ชั้น 2
ชั้น 3 ใช่ไหมถ้าร้านครูร้านอาหารเนี่ย
อยู่ชั้น 3 แล้วร้านขายเสื้อที่ครูฟ้าถาม
อาจจะเป็นแบรนด์สมมติ Adidas อย่างนี้ถ้า
อยู่ชั้น 3 เหมือนกันคิดว่าเขาจะรู้เพราะ
ว่าเขาทำงานที่ห้างใช่ไหมทุกวันเนี่ยเดิน
ๆน่าจะเข้าใจนะคะหรืออีกอย่างหนึ่งที่ผู้
หญิงคิดว่าเราถามคนที่ทำงานในห้างถามร้าน
ในห้างได้ก็คือถามห้องน้ำไหม
ถ้าเราอยากถามว่าเออชั้น 3 หรือว่าชั้น 4
ชั้น 5 นักเรียนเดินอยู่ชั้นไหนนะคะแล้ว
อยากจะถามว่าห้องน้ำเนี่ยอยู่ตรงไหนอยู่
ที่ไหนคิดว่าอันนี้นักเรียนไม่ต้องเดินหา
information นะคะ
ใช้เทคนิคแบบครูฟ้าดีกว่า 3 คนทำงานใน
ห้างแบบร้านอาหารร้านขายเสื้อร้านขาย
ลิปสติกอะไรอย่างนี้ค่ะถามคนในห้างคุณคิด
ว่าเขารู้ว่าห้องน้ำอยู่ตรงไหน
ใช่ค่ะครูฟ้าก็คิดว่าเขารู้ค่ะ
แต่ถ้านักเรียนเนี่ยไม่ได้อยู่ในห้างใช่
ไหมคะบางทีเนี่ยนักเรียนชอบเดิน
เดินก็จะเดินบนฟุตบาทใช่ไหมคะ
ใช่
อันนี้นักเรียนก็จะเดินที่นี่เนาะบนถนนก็
จะมีรถนะคะ
อย่าไปเดินบนถนนนะคะเดี๋ยวรถชนนะคะบางที
นักเรียนเนี่ยเดินใช่ไหมคะเดินอยู่ตรง
อยู่บนฟุตบาทอันนี้นักเรียนเนาะ
แล้วก็อาจจะเจอคนไทยอย่างนี้ถ้านักเรียน
ส่วนใหญ่เลยคิดว่านักเรียนเนี่ยจะถามทาง
ว่า
เซ็นทรัลเวิลด์อยู่ที่ไหน
หรือว่าแบรนด์พาเลซอยู่ที่ไหนนักเรียนจะ
ถามทาง
โอเคไหม
โอเคนะ
บางทีคนไทยเนี่ยก็จะพูดอ๋อเดินใช่ไหมเดิน
ตรงไป
แล้วก็เลี้ยวซ้ายเลี้ยวซ้ายก็จะเห็นที่
นี่
เซ็นทรัลเวิลด์หรือถ้าคนไทยไม่พูดก็จะชี้
ใช่ไหม
[เพลง]
คะเขาก็อาจจะชี้ส่วนใหญ่หรือครูหญิงกับ
ครูฟ้าก็ได้นะเราก็ถามทางได้ใช่ค่ะแต่ถ้า
นักเรียนเดินมาเจอครูฟ้าเนี่ยนะคะ
นักเรียนเดินมาเจอเอ้าครูฟ้า
ฟ้า
โอเค
เดี๋ยวครูฟ้าเปิดให้ว่าไปยังไงยังไง
คือนักเรียนเนี่ย
ก็ได้
ไม่ต้องถามคนอื่น
คือคนไทยบางคนเขาก็ไม่รู้นะคะนักเรียนก็
ถามนั่นแหละถามก็ได้ถามคนนี้คนนี้รู้ก็
โอเคถามคนนี้คนนี้ไม่รู้ก็ไปถามคนนู้น
หรือว่าง่ายๆไงใช้เทคนิคเดียวกับครูฟ้า
แบบในห้างก็ได้นะคะเวลานักเรียนเดินที่
ฟุตบาทใช่ไหมตรงนี้มันก็จะเป็นตึกบางที
มันจะมีพวกร้านน่ะร้านอาหารหรือว่าพวกคน
ที่เขาขายสตรีทฟู้ดเป็นรถเข็นอย่างนี้ถ้า
ถามเขาคิดว่าเขาอาจจะรู้มากกว่าคนไทยที่
เดินไปเดินมานะ
คะ
หรือว่าอีกอย่างนึงที่ครูหญิงคิดว่านัก
เรียนอาจจะอาจจะใช้ถามหรือคนไทยเองก็ถาม
ได้นะคะเพราะว่าบางทีเนี่ยเราอยู่ที่
กรุงเทพฯใช่ไหมคะแล้วเราอยากไปไปหลายๆที่
เนี่ยไม่ใช่ทุกที่เนี่ยมีรถไฟฟ้าไปได้ใช่
ไหม
กรุงเทพฯเนี่ยจะมีรถไฟฟ้านะคะซับเวย์อ่ะ
เนาะ Sky  Train ทั้งหลายนะคะ BTS หรือ
ว่า
MRT ใช่ไหมคะแต่บางครั้งเนี่ย BTS สมมติ
นักเรียนอยากไป Grand  Palace  BTS เนี่ย
ไม่ได้แน่นอนแต่ MRT อาจจะต้องเดินเดิน
ไกลนักเรียนอาจจะอยากออกมาประเทศไทยทั้ง
ทีก็อยากจะนั่งรถเมล์ใช่ไหมคะนี่
รถเมล์ให้นะคะ
เมย์อยากจะนั่งรถเมล์แต่ว่านักเรียนไม่
รู้ว่ารถเมล์เนี่ยมันจะมีเบอร์อย่างเช่น
เบอร์ 2  0  1
เบอร์ 17
เบอร์ 1 เบอร์ 74 นักเรียนก็ไม่รู้ว่า
รถเมล์
จะเป็นคนขับใช่ไหม
คะขอโทษอันนี้ไม่ใช่รถเมล์ประเทศไทยนะคะ
คนขับเขาพูดภาษาอังกฤษได้ไหม
ไม่ได้มั้งไม่รู้
นักเรียนต้องพูดภาษาไทย
ใช่แต่ถ้าครูหญิงกับครูฟ้าเป็นคนไทยเนี่ย
สบายเพราะว่าเราพูดภาษาไทยได้แต่นักเรียน
พูดภาษาไทยไม่ได้ผู้หญิงคิดว่านักเรียน
พูด Grand  Palace
คิดว่าเขาเข้าใจได้นะ
หรอเพราะว่ารถเมล์บางคันจากกรุงเทพฯเนี่ย
จะมีรถเมล์ Number  15 นะคะ
รถเมล์สีแดง
สีแดงเนี่ยแล้วก็ผ่าน mvk แกรนด์พาเลซ
ข้าวสารข้าวสาร Road พวกนี้
บางทีเขาจะมีภาษาอังกฤษด้วยบางทีคนขับอ่ะ
เขาอาจจะพูดหรือฟังภาษาอังกฤษไม่ได้เก่ง
แต่เขาเข้าใจคำว่า Grand  Palace พอดีคน
ต่างชาติขึ้นอย่างนี้นักเรียนอาจจะใช้
คีย์เวิร์ดหนึ่งคำพอไม่ต้องถามยาวๆนะคะ
เพราะถ้านักเรียนพูดแบบรถเมล์คันนี้ไป
Grand  Palace ไหมผ่าน Grand  Palace
ไหมเนี่ยคนไทยพอได้ยินภาษาอังกฤษเนี่ยไม่
เข้าใจแล้วนักเรียนก็พูดแข็งแกรนพาเลซ
ข้าวสารวัดโพธิ์พูดแค่บางคำอันนี้ก็ถามคน
ขับได้แต่ถ้าไม่อยากถามคนขับตรงนี้มันจะ
เป็นป้ายรถเมล์ใช่ไหมคะมีคน
คนยืนรอรถเมล์เยอะๆก็ถามได้อันนี้ก็ถาม
ได้ว่าเออมีรถเมล์ไปแกรนด์พาเลซไหมถ้ารอ
ที่นี่เบอร์อะไรอย่างนี้ค่ะเราก็ถามได้
ใช่ไหมคะจริงๆแล้วเวลาที่เรายังเราอยู่
ที่อื่นแล้วเราไม่รู้เราก็ถามเขาได้ถ้า
เป็นคนไทยนักเรียนก็พูดก่อนว่าขอโทษนะคะ
ผู้หญิง
[เพลง]
ผู้ชายก็ขอโทษนะครับแล้วก็ถามถ้านักเรียน
พูดภาษาไทยได้แล้ว
นักเรียนพูดไม่ได้ก็พูดภาษาอังกฤษนะคะแต่
ไม่ต้องไปสะกิดนะเดี๋ยวคนไทยตกใจนะคะนั่น
แหละค่ะก็เป็นการ
ถามคนอื่นเนาะส่วนวีดีโอนี้นะคะหมดเวลา
แล้วเดี๋ยวเรามาเจอกันใหม่วีดีโอหน้านะคะ
นักเรียนสวัสดีค่ะสวัสดีค่ะ